TO AND WHAT THEY NEED TO DO.
>> STRANGE YEAR.
ALEX, THANK YOU.
>> OF COURSE THE PANDEMIC HAS
SLAMMED THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY,
FORCING MANY TO CLOSE AND IN
SOME AREAS ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
NEW RESTRICTIONS ARE MAKING IT
HARDER FOR THEM TO SURVIVE.
LET’S BRING IN ROBERT ST. JOHN,
INDEPENDENT RESTAURANT
COALITION.
HE OWNS SEVERAL RESTAURANTS AND
HAS BEEN TO THE BUSINESS FOR 4
DECADES.
GETTING RIGHT TO THE POINT, HOW
DIFFICULT IS IT?
>> HAPPY THANKSGIVING.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON.
IN THE SEASON OF GRATITUDE AND
THANKS, I’M GOING TO TELL YOU,
THANKS TO WHAT YOU HAVE DONE,
YOUR FAMILY, HIS LATE FATHER,
ALL THE COUSINS AND WHAT THEY’VE
MEANT TO THE MUSIC INDUSTRY.
IT’S THINGS LIKE THAT THAT HAVE
HELPED US GET THROUGH THESE
TIMES.
THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY IS IN
CRISIS RIGHT NOW.
NO OTHER INDUSTRY HAS BEEN HIT
AS HARD AS THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY HAS BEEN HIT.
THERE ARE 11 MILLION INDEPENDENT
RESTAURANTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
500,000, 11 MILLION EMPLOYEES
AND ANOTHER 500,000 EMPLOYEES,
FARMERS, OTHER JOBS IN THE
RESTAURANT BUSINESS.
IT’S DEVASTATING RIGHT NOW.
>> IT’S REALLY IS.
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY TO
CONGRESS?
>> WHAT I WANT TO TELL YOU IS
THAT I’VE BEEN IN MISSISSIPPI,
MY HOME STATE SENATOR, HE’S
INTRODUCED A BILL THAT’S CALLED
THE RESTAURANTS ACT, IT’S
SITTING IN THE SENATE RIGHT NOW.
IT IS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THERE ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE.
SENATOR SCHUMER, KAMALA HARRIS,
ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE HAVE
COSIGNED.
HALF OF THE SENATE HAS SIGNED
IT.
IT WILL SAVE THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY.
IT NEEDS TO BE PASSED.
HERE’S THE THING, PPE WAS GOOD,
BUT ONLY 8% WENT TO RESTAURANTS
AND BARS.
WE ACCOUNT FOR 25% OF THE
NATION’S JOBS.
PPE WAS A 24 WEEK FIX, 18TH
MONTH PROBLEM.
EVERY ONCE PPE HAS RUN OUT AND
RESTAURANTS ARE CLOSING.
NOW YOU HAVE A WEATHER COMING IN
IN.
SOME OF MY FRIENDS IN COLORADO
WHO WERE DOING GREAT WITH
OUTDOOR DYING, IT’S SNOWING
THERE NOW
>> AND THEIR RESTRICTIONS AND
OUTLAY, THEY REPORT THE
RESTAURANTS HAVE TO CLOSE AT
10:00 P.M., THE ONES WHO WERE
ABLE TO OPEN AN ADULT.
I WANT TO JUMP IN BECAUSE I
HEARD YOU LOUD AND CLEAR THAT
YOU WANT CONGRESS TO PASS
SOMETHING.
WHAT I WANT TO DO RIGHT NOW IS
MENTION YOUR WEBSITE.
I UNDERSTAND YOUR WEBSITE IS
SAVE RESTAURANTS.COM.
VIEWERS CAN GO THERE AND ALMOST
SPEAK DIRECTLY TO CONGRESS.
LET THEM KNOW THEY STAND WITH
YOU AND SOMETHING NEEDS TO GET
DONE NOW.
YES?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THE HOUSE HAS PASSED THE BILL.
IT’S IN THE SENATE.
IT HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
WE CAN GET THIS DONE.
YOU CAN SAVE RESTAURANTS.
WINTER IS COMING AND WINTER IS
HERE FOR THE RESTAURANT BUSINESS
AND IT’S GOING TO BE ROUGH.
WE EMPLOY OVER 1 MILLION SINGLE
MOMS.
60 MILLION COME FROM A
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITY.
I GREW UP WITH A SINGLE MOM.
SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT 11 MILLION
WORKERS IN AMERICA.
2.4% UNEMPLOYMENT CAN BE
IMPROVED RIGHT NOW.
>> ROBERT ST. JOHN, SORRY TO CUT
YOU OFF.
I WANT TO TELL YOU, THANK YOU
FOR THE KIND WORDS YOU SAID
ABOUT MY FAMILY.
UNCLE AARON IS WATCHING.